la parole est maintenant président
Longeot pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour
examiner une initiative initiative
bienvenue de mon excellente collègue
Vincent capo Cannella cette proposition
de loi est très attendue par les acteurs
du transport aérien mais aussi et
surtout par les usagers les derniers
mois ont été particulièrement difficiles
pour le secteur aérien comme la très
juste me rappeler la rapporteur Évelyne
Perrault le déroulement des grèves
consécutives à la réforme des retraites
au sein de la Direction générale de
l'aviation civile a montré la façon très
claire des limites du système actuel
il n'y a aucune prévisibilité de trafic
la DGAC doit naviguer ou plutôt piloter
à vue pour déterminer la proportion de
vol à annuler parce que elle ne dispose
donc un outil pour connaître
suffisamment tôt le nombre de
contrôleurs aériens qui vont participer
au mouvement de grève quelques grévistes
peuvent amener à des abattements massifs
de vol et engendré de fortes
perturbations en totale disproportion
avec l'ampleur réelle du mouvement
le double objectif de cette proposition
de loi est donc tout à fait louable une
meilleure prévisibilité des grèves et
plus d'adéquation entre leur ampleur et
la réduction du trafic le moyen prévu la
déclaration individuelle préalable un
double avantage d'une part il est très
efficace la prévisibilité du trafic
serait assurée avec la création de cette
déclaration la DGAC disposerait d'un
ciel dégagé pour anticiper l'ampleur
réel de la grève des dispositifs
analogues existent déjà pour toute pour
tous les autres professionnels du
secteur aérien ainsi que dans le secteur
ferroviaire et ils ont fait preuve de
leur efficacité on a bien vu la
différence de 6 juin dernier 30% des
vols avaient été annulés à l'aéroport de
Paris Orly alors qu'il n'y avait
quasiment pas eu d'annulation de train
SNCF
d'autre part ce moyen très très peu
contraignant la déclaration individuelle
n'empêche pas aucunement de participer à
la grève elle demande simplement au
grévistes de se signaler l'avant veille
de la grève elle n'empêche pas non plus
qu'il y ait des perturbations du trafic
quand il y a une grève de forte ampleur
elle met simplement un terme à une
aberration aberration l'existence de
grève très peu suivie souvent déclenché
pour des motifs qui sont complètement
extérieurs aux transports aérien et qui
perturbe fortement le trafic ce texte
équilibré permettra un atterrissage en
douceur du système actuel car je pense
qu'il répond également à de nombreuses
difficultés que rencontre les
contrôleurs aériens dans leur vie
professionnelle
ces derniers je crois ont tout à gagner
à ceux qui soient adopté afin que le
service minimum puisse être organisé
avec plus de sérénité et surtout que
l'on y est recours moins fréquemment le
dialogue social en sortira très
renforcée j'espère par ailleurs à ce
propos que le gouvernement mettra en
oeuvre le plus rapidement possible la
mise à jour attendu par tous du cadre
réglementaire du service minimum qui est
aujourd'hui obsolète le secteur aérien a
subi avec la crise sanitaire l'une des
plus grandes crises de son histoire
innocent n'est pas encore remis en
février dernier le trafic aérien
atteignait environ que 84% de son niveau
2019 en mars dernier il est tombé à
moins de 87%
et compagnies françaises sont les plus
touchés par les conséquences des grèves
du contrôle aérien la proportion de vol
qu'elles ont assuré en mars dernier par
rapport à mars 2019 en France n'est que
de 85% contre 88 pour les compagnies
étrangères elle doit faire face à de
très nombreuses défis pour mener à bien
mais n'ira bien la transition écologique
dans notre pays et font preuve d'un
engagement intense pour la décarbonation
de leur activité dans ce ciel si elle
incertain il est donc nécessaire
aujourd'hui de limiter au maximum les
turbulences que peut rencontrer le
secteur afin qu'ils puissent retrouver
sa vitesse de croisière le plus
rapidement possible je soutiens donc
pleinement l'excellente initiative de
Vincent Kapo canela qui a su mené
un exercice de haute voltige écrire un
texte acceptable pour tous et qui roule
et qui résout avec le moins de
contraintes possibles un max un maximum
de situations problématique je tiens à
le remercier ainsi que la rapporteur
Évelyne Perrot qui s'est pleinement
investi sur ce sujet sujet aussi
complexe qu'essentiel pour nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
et la dernière oratrice Catherine pro
catche